[Music]
Bloody Bay
play-day who dare tell men a great bag I
do
transformers 5 came out last week that's
lucky number 13 13 feature films
directed by Paulo
this guy day has actually been around
since the late 80s before his first
feature bad boys in 1995 he directed a
ton of music videos knowing that you can
see that style across most of his movies
and the very striking images he's known
for while he does have some classic
action films under his belt like the
rock and Armageddon nowadays he seemed
to be the poster boy for loud super
heavy action blockbusters like the
transformer series he's only directed to
non transformer movies since helming the
first in 2007 but are considered his
worst films though let's dive in and
roll out these are the top 5 worst
Michael Bay movie number 5 bad boys to a
lot of people like the bad boys movies
and I'll admit they're not all that
terrible but I need something to put at
the number 5 spot what was I going to
put painting game no the racks in that
yeah the rocks in that police detective
Marcus Burnett and Mike Lowrey our
partners on the force and friends
outside of it
when ecstasy starts to become an
epidemic in Miami the two cops traced
the drugs to a Cuban smuggler who
simultaneously involved in a war with a
Russian mob as the stressful case drags
on Burnett and Lauer's friendship begins
to strain and matters are made worse
when it's revealed Burnett sister Sid
has been dating Lowrey Sid is also
working for the DEA and the trio end up
working to catch the same bad guy
Martin Lawrence and Will Smith are
entertaining enough in this movie what's
not great here is everything surrounding
them like rats having sex
- Papa Rex hoping the shit out of this
mama rap you straight rise enough or
comically running over dead bodies bad
boys - is definitely as lewd as can be
what it's rainin are what do you expect
okay didn't expect the rat sex or this
we need your cock
alright get up can you not get a better
card Annette let that man go so he's
coming at me with that call Mike freak I
really should have been an actor freak
honk-honk explosion number four Pearl
Harbor look I already had to talk about
this movie when discussing Ben Affleck's
worst performances and having to watch
it again sucked because this movie sucks
of course based on the real-life
bombings in 1941 Pearl Harbor uses the
attacks as a backdrop for a love
triangle between lieutenant Evelyn
Johnson and childhood best friends first
lieutenant race Macaulay and first
lieutenant Danny Walker rape and Evelyn
become an item before he volunteers to
help the Allies overseas while their
waste plane goes down and he pronounced
dead together in mourning Danny and
Evelyn become close and eventually form
a romantic relationship rape is later
found to be alive and his return is met
with confusion among his friends there's
not much time for Danni and Rafe to talk
things out before Pearl Harbor is bombed
and the resulting action by the u.s. to
formally get involved in world war two
every time I see this movie I like it
less it's over three hours long over
three hours of Dawson's Creek the war
years what I find funny about this now
is how we have the Japanese leaders
being played by a coup and Shang soon
for moral combat
yo so is mine I oh and dad's there too
the only decent parts of this movie are
the actual bombing sequence and pretty
much anything with Cuba Gooding jr. why
couldn't this movie just be about him
and the events surrounding the attacks I
hate the love triangle on this I hate
the simplification of one of the biggest
tragedies in American history I hate Dan
Aykroyd I hate it all why was this movie
made this way why they because love and
explosions and love number 3
Transformers Dark of the Moon and so it
begins
Sentinel Prime was once the leader of
the Autobots during the war on Cybertron
when he discovered an Earth's moon
Optimus Prime thinks bringing him back
to life will bring victory to his team
Megatron and the Decepticons have other
ideas as all-out war breaks out in
Chicago meanwhile Sam Witwicky and his
new girlfriend Carly get back involved
in the fray after Sam has trouble
finding a job I hadn't seen this since
it was in theaters and I'm not going to
lie I couldn't get through it in one
sitting
I thought Shia was at least bearable in
the first two films in this franchise
but here Jewellery watching my talk to
collectors
Oh his parents are even worse
he's a millennial that means they're the
you know like lost generation they had
an argument when you fight but you're
not going to get a third one I mean
unless you have like a what does mom mom
mom tomorrow what you don't talk about
this anymore look they got Leonard Nimoy
to voice Sentinel Prime in this sounds
like a good idea
oh wait no that's the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the people yes we
did it
you a Spock I know this is just a
Chicago thing but this bothered all of
us we're gonna use Willis power for
Chagas yes I for destroying your city
there Lisa we brought back two new jobs
while we chop the newer film here we
didn't we didn't screw you Chicago
number two transformers age of
extinction
I object Mark Wahlberg as Cade Yeager
the most compelling performances Mike
Myers in the Love Guru
she's an inventor yes we know I'm an
inventor five years after the Battle of
Chicago all transformers are outlaws
when inventor Cade Yeager discovers an
old truck he gets more than he bargained
for as that truck turns out to be none
other than Optimus Prime himself as new
threat to rise and with caves family by
their sides
the Autobots now must reconvene as
they're hunted by human and transformer
alike they tried changing things up here
with new human characters and it felt
fresh first if this movie was an hour
shorter I might have been able to get
through it without falling asleep at 2
hours and 45 minutes it crushes any
goodwill it built up in the first act
and turns into the same mindless crap
the previous two movies were and
seriously what the is up with the creepy
underage stuff in this movie it's not
cute it's not funny
it's freaking weird 17 you go girl well
protected by the Romeo and Juliet laws I
think you worked hard I'm basically your
uncle I think you look hot
I'm basically your uncle I think you
looked hot they tried to bring some
gravitas to this movie with Kelsey
Grammer and Stanley Tucci but they don't
bring this movie up this movie brings
them down the movie
nowadays that's the trouble sequels and
remakes bunch of crap yeah nice and the
number one worst Michael Bay movie is
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen this
list is a first assist movie made over
800 million dollars at the box office
people love it you'll love it your
11,000 iesson so sanaya widths and
leaving for college and the Autobots
working with the American military
things seem to have settled down on
earth two years after the first
transformers battle however everyone is
pulled back into the fight when Megatron
is resurrected and in ancient Decepticon
called the Fallen re-emerges on earth
it's up to Sam his girlfriend mckaela
and the remaining Autobots to defeat
these dangerous new foes I'm running out
of things to say these movies are all
the same I think it may be a general
consensus that this is the worst of the
Transformers sequels though I mean we do
get more animal sex in general humping
mojo note dominating Frankie say my name
say my name
what are you allowing to happen you
purchase them Reese's Facebook fan
yeah well he's faithful and he's nude
and he's pure D this is the wit wiki's
at their worst I'm talking in sufferable
they based it with reefer in it yeah
give me it's my cheat day I'm a freak
off thank you faster I'd do anything for
an a is that a bad boy stool poster
really BAE
I thought about putting a meatloaf
poster in there but that seems a little
much Michael Bay has shown that he can
make fun and more importantly tolerable
movies he says this latest transformers
sequel is the last he'll direct time
will tell if that's true and we'll
finally get something a little different
from him like 13 hours from last year
for now though he'll continue to be
known as the guy who directed this
oh whatever you may mock my transformer
screams but you've seen transformer
sighs is that all I need just need you
to see my movies to get your money in my
pocket to do with it as I wish you know
what I wish to do with it make more
transformer movie so all I need for us s
seein as you make fun of it and the
explosions will never stop it the reign
of Fame uh slow ha ha ha ha
actually I didn't see transformers 5 I
did you like ya don't plan it either no
I need people to see my movies in order
for my career to exist
no I'm family ding ding oh what a world
what a lousy career loves explosions on
uh I want to hear what you guys think
what is your least favorite Michael Bay
movie what do you want me to cover next
in the show
leave a comment and let me know for more
content subscribed to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome Walter
like my new Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome altered beef and follow me
on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what may be covered in the future
come back next week as we count down the
top 5 best nostalgia critic episodes see
you then
[Music]
you